[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 27 novembre
bienvenue dans le journal de tv 78 le
tour de l'actualité locale en 26 minutes
voici les titres de cette édition un an
précisément qu'elle a été lancée à
guyancourt inauguré par trois ministres
une plate forme de signalement des
violences sexuelles a été mise en place
au commissariat de la ville
un portail en ligne où il est possible
de chatter avec un policier plus de 1000
tracteurs dans les rues de paris
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs se
mobilisaient pour faire pression
notamment sur les négociations
commerciales avec la grande distribution
le cortège est passé par les routes
yvelinoise tôt ce matin et un nouveau
bâtiment bientôt pour le technocentre
renault à guyancourt odyssée va
accueillir 700 collaborateurs cet
immeuble qui sera en voie s'inscrit dans
le programme de rénovation du site
on parle tout alors aussi du black
friday qui a lieu vendredi bien
connaître cette opération commerciale et
éviter les fausses bonnes affaires avec
l'association ufc que choisir région de
versailles
une date anniversaire ce 27 novembre il
ya un an et étayent inauguré au
commissariat de guyancourt une
plateforme pour signaler est les
violences sexuelles et sexistes il en
existe seulement deux en france tel est
le bilan après la mise en place de ce
dispositif
éléments de réponse avec aurélien une
conversation anonyme entre un policier
et une victime de violences sexuelles
sexistes ou conjugal depuis un an 18
policiers se relaie 7 jours sur 7 au 3e
étage du commissariat de guyancourt
inauguré par plusieurs ministres à cette
plateforme permet aux victimes de
pouvoir s'exprimer ou se confier
plus de 5000 signalements ont été
enregistrés dont 35% été transmis aux
services territoriaux pour des dépôts de
plainte ou encore des prises de procès
verbaux nous avons des chat qui viennent
d'outre-mer mais également d'un peu
partout en france surtout sur des
grosses villes on peut quand même dire
que paris bordeaux lyon lille
beaucoup plus de contacts chat que deux
villes un peu plus petite au centre de
la france en moyenne un chat avec une
une victime c'est environ 54 minutes
c'est une moyenne
on a des tchats beaucoup plus longs qui
peuvent durer jusqu'à deux heures les
signalements concernent en premier les
violences sexuelles
viennent ensuite les violences
conjugales et les violences sexistes
tous ces policiers ont reçu une
formation spécifique et sont épaulés par
camille puni c'est la psychologue de
cette plateforme
elle et sa compagne quotidien il y en a
qui apprécient pouvoir durant un temps
ensuite parlé avec moi de certains de
chappe qu'ils ont mieux qu'ils ont pu
plus les marques et que d'autres
j'essaie de rester au maximum disponible
pour pouvoir répondre à toutes leurs
questions
sachant que le but c'est qu'il soit
quand même autonome qui puisse répondre
eux mêmes aux victimes
moi je suis un peu le filet de secours
lorsque effectivement sont en difficulté
la plateforme ouverte à toutes et tous
pourrait être amené à évoluer avec le
recrutement de nouveaux opérateurs ou
l'élargissement du domaine des
infractions il sillonne les yvelines et
les hauts-de-seine un bus de la santé
des femmes vient d'être lancée derrière
le projet le soutien des deux
collectivités franciliennes
marylène iapichino s'est rendu à son
inauguration c'était à l'hôtel du
département du 92 à nanterre un bus 30
mètres carrés avec ses espaces définis
et huit personnes pour accompagner des
femmes en situation d'isolement c'est le
projet qui tenait à coeur à la
directrice de l'institut des
hauts-de-seine un an et demi de
prospection et de réunion pour arriver
aujourd'hui à la création de ce premier
bus santé des femmes j'avais vraiment la
volonté de le faire parce que ça répond
vraiment à un manque
un manque il n'y a pas de structure pour
accompagner la solitude de la femme il
ya des structures pour le handicap des
structures pour la plage il ya des
structures pour la précarité
mais la solitude c'est une urgence
sociale qui n'est pas encore défini par
par nos hommes politiques et par nos
gouvernants deux cent mille euros
d'investissement réunis grâce à la
région ile de france les départements
des yvelines et des hauts-de-seine et un
partenariat avec la ratp 72
interventions sont programmées en 2020
36 dans chaque département l'itinérance
c'est pour aller au plus près de ces
populations isolées
nous on a déjà testé l'itinérance dans
le département des yvelines avec un bus
pmi et ça fonctionne bien on va vers des
publics qui peuvent avoir des
difficultés pour quelques raisons que ce
soit à se déplacer des professionnels de
santé une coordinatrice pour assurer
l'accueil des femmes et du personnel
juridique l'ordre des avocats des
hauts-de-seine le barreau de versailles
et l'ordre des médecins du 92 ont
répondu présent pour ce projet une vraie
collaboration possible grâce à ce bus de
la ratp entièrement réhabilité on va
apporter aussi un soutien à la fois
logistiques puisqu'on prête le bus
et puis on met à disposition donc des
salariés pour permettre tout simplement
de conduire le bus des salariés
volontaires ils conduiront ce bus pour
une première dans les yvelines le 2
décembre à rambouillet et le 3 à
conflans sainte honorine détracteurs dès
l'aube sur les routes yvelinoise
plusieurs agriculteurs se sont retrouvés
dans le département afin de converger
vers paris une opération escargot pour
dénoncer leur ras-le-bol leur ras-le-bol
des reportages ce matin à dainville au
départ de brazzaville de nicolas landry
et de manon baradeau ce matin dès l'aube
les agriculteurs ont manifesté pour
faire entendre leur ras-le-bol
ils ont répondu à la mobilisation lancé
par la fédération nationale des
syndicats d'exploitants agricoles et des
jeunes agriculteurs
parmi les manifestants cet agriculteur
installé depuis quatre ans sur 170
hectares
là c'est vraiment un cumul de tous
aujourd'hui on nous parle de 350 mètres
aux abords des maisons de zones aux
traitements donc pour nous ça c'est un
scandale totalement parce que c'est une
perte de revenu sur ces bandes là qui va
payer les fermages au aux propriétaires
qui va indemniser les agriculteurs sur
les pertes
les agriculteurs ont mené l'opération
escargot départ de base en ville ils se
sont dirigés sur la nationale 12 pour
rejoindre un autre cortège à montfort
l'amaury ils ont regagné le triangle de
rocquencourt pour se fondre avec les
tracteurs qui arrivait de mantes la
jolie dans le cortège beaucoup de
pancartes macron à répond elle les
agriculteurs se sont délaissés par le
gouvernement le gouvernement veut
peut-être aujourd'hui que on devienne et
fonctionnaires de l'état d'entretien de
la nature c'est à dire peut-être que
dans dix ans on va recevoir 1500 euros
par mois pour pas entretenir les champs
pour faire plaisir au gouvernement parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
al'impression on est lâché
c'est tout bonnement un ras-le-bol
moi j'arrive en fin de carrière mais je
voudrais bien aimé finir plus calmement
et puis je suis inquiet pour les jeunes
qui viennent derrière parce que bon ben
ça va quand même être très difficile la
loi dite et galim issues des états
généraux de l'alimentation est mise en
place en début d'année était censé
ramener du revenu aux exploitants en
rééquilibrant les relations commerciales
pourtant ce céréalier et éleveur ne
perçoit pas de différence et l'expriment
sur ces panneaux français vêtue encore
de thé agriculteurs l'agriculture
française c'est une des premières
puissances économiques du pays et en tue
cette agriculture on tue cette économie
on alerte demain aujourd'hui on est
capable de nourrir notre population
demain on va importer et on mangera du
grand n'importe quoi et ça c'est
vraiment ça me désole pour mes enfants
pour mes petits neveux pour mes voisins
et pour tous les français
les agriculteurs se sont ensuite dirigés
sur le périphérique parisien pour tous
se rejoindre sur l'avenue foch à 10h30
le 23 septembre dernier et les
agriculteurs s'étaient déjà mobilisés
dans plusieurs départements d'île de
france
une délégation d'agriculteurs devaient
être reçus tout à l'heure à 17 heures au
ministère de l'agriculture par ailleurs
si vous empruntez les routes attention
la police nationale indique que des
ralentissements sont probables sur l'a13
la n12 et la 12 dans le sens
paris-province odyssée c'est le nom de
ce nouveau bâtiment qui va voir le jour
au technocentre renault de guyancourt un
chantier actuellement en cours et
débuter cet été
ce projet s'inscrit dans le plan de
rénovation du site de la marque au
losange nicolas landry a suivi ce matin
une visite organisée sur place ce sera
un bâtiment tout en bois du sol au
plafond une nouvelle structure au sein
du technocentre renault de guyancourt
son nom odyssée une appellation choisie
par les collaborateurs du site
un chantier démarré cet été avec la pose
des premiers piliers en bois en octobre
dernier
vous voyez à cet endroit là l'assemblage
des poteaux des poutres et des planchers
qui se fait de façon simultanée donc de
façon très rapide
l'ensemble et lycées là c'est la partie
qui va encore durer un mois et demi à
peu près pour élever la principale
structure
ensuite on va y apposer les façades ce
nouveau bâtiment de 12 mille mètres
carrés accueillera près de 700
collaborateurs
il s'inscrit dans le large projet de
rénovation du site
le programme efficience du technocentre
renault aujourd'hui tout a changé dans
les modes de travail en particulier dans
les modes de travail de l'ingénierie et
on a besoin de se mettre en lien avec
toutes les nouveautés du mode de
fonctionnement et l'organisation dans
l'espace doit être en phase avec la
manière dont les gens travaillent
ce nouvel immeuble va nous donner 700
places de plus qui va nous permettre d
idées entre guillemets la ruche pour
accélérer les travaux dans la ruche
effectivement les mobiliers innovants
que nous avions présenté il ya quelques
semaines seront dans ce bâtiment ce site
de recherche et développement a ouvert
ses portes en 1998 il couvre une surface
de 150 hectares
emploie près de onze mille personnes un
site important pour l'économie du
territoire
la livraison du bâtiment est prévue pour
l'été prochain les collaborateurs
intégreront le site entre septembre et
novembre 2020
cette opération commerciale permet de
trouver des produits à prix réduits et
ce à quelques jours des fêtes de fin
d'année le black friday débutera
officiellement ce vendredi est même si
de nombreuses enseignes proposent déjà
des promotions depuis le début de la
semaine lundi le cyber monday que le
tueur à cette période de rabais est de
bonne affaire certes mais gare au piège
on en parle avec vous philippe le ray
bonsoir soit administrateur de
l'association ufc que choisir région de
versailles
le black friday c'est une opération qui
est venu des états unis et qui est somme
toute assez récente en france depuis
2014 c'est en place sur le territoire
est ce que ça mobilise de plus en plus
l'attention
le travail des bénévoles du ufc que
choisir non on va voir ça mais au niveau
local pas forcément mais nous ce que
l'on constate si vous laissez qu' il y à
un matraquage finalement publicitaires
notamment et les informations qui sont
données notamment via internet ont
échangé tout à l'heure en off depuis le
début de la semaine par exemple j'ai
reçu déjà 5 annonce le black friday sur
mon téléphone oui mais multiplient mais
oui ça se multiplient alors tout ça donc
il faut bien comprendre que pour le
l'inventeur nice est un événement
considérable faut savoir que par rapport
à vendredi
normal le jour du black friday
ça correspond à 4 4% de transactions en
plus en nombre quatre vingt quatre pour
une estime environ un milliard d'euros
qui pourrait être dépensé ce jour des
rangs ligne c'est considérable et il ya
une vigilance particulière de
l'association oui on a fait des études
je veux donner cette de l'an passé on a
examiné des milliers d'articles sur les
différents sites de les grands
distributeurs en ligne et on s'aperçoit
que par rapport au rabé aux promotions
annoncées le la réalité et pas ce qui
est annoncé c'est à dire que on va
déraper à écrire en hausse et à 60%
réalité ça concerne très peu d'articles
ou bien c'est par rapport à des plis du
passé par rapport à des prix recommandé
par les fabricants mais ce n'est pas la
réalité plus de temps que par rapport
aux soldes dont vous êtes déjà venu
parler en plateau le black friday n'est
pas encadrée juridiquement
non non ça vient des états unis et c'est
quelque chose qui concerne
essentiellement internet et maintenant
les autres commerçants sont obligés de
s'y mettre parce que voyez un tel
matraquage qui se sentent obligés non
justement avez vous prévu de participer
au black friday patrick jacques de
dixmude et raphaël fournier sont allés
poser la question à quelques yvelinois
ça m'intéresse pas et je trouve que
c'est encore une action de plus pour
faire consommer 10 ans a progressé
l'année dernière mais cette année il est
bien aussi
d'abord parce que nous n'achetons pas
quelques petites choses que vous états
unis donc sur des sites américains
avec ses quelque chose qu'on suit depuis
longtemps pour ça et
et après c'est vrai que comme c'est un
mois avant noël on a tendance à regarder
si j'étais pas tout à fait prête pour ça
mais on a fait quelques achats sur des
sites étrangers et les soldes avant et
se faire les soldes de janvier ça
obligeait à consommer beaucoup des trucs
dont on n'a pas besoin je suis pas sûr
que ce soit vraiment bien les gens ont
besoin de faire des affaires et socotec
de faire des affaires on achète en
quantité des choses qui sont pas
forcément utiles
ça m'a fait beaucoup de choses mais si
vous me donnez ap de soja peut y aller
pour moi là-bas c'était une journée et
maintenant ça s'est transformé en une
semaine ça peut être intéressant au vu
des promotions mais bon ça rejoint un
peu l'idée de
trop dépenser acheter ce qu'on n'a pas
forcément besoin à celui qui a besoin
d'acheter un téléviseur par exemple ça
beaucoup il ya des années qu'on ait des
choses intéressantes mais à part ça le
reste
moi je crois que je pourrais y
participer en tout près d'un français
sur deux devrait participer au black
friday pour un budget moyen de 250 euros
selon une enquête d'opinion way je vous
pose la question directement philippe le
ray est ce que le black friday ce qu'on
y fait des bonnes affaires ou finalement
pas pendant cette période on peut faire
des affaires
il faut être honnête mais pas dans les
proportions de ce qui est annoncé
est-ce qu'il faut savoir également c'est
que les prix ont tendance à être un peu
plus faible la dernière semaine de
novembre est la première semaine de
décembre
mais pas seulement le veut ce vendredi
là donc il faut rassurer les
consommateurs ne pas s'affoler examiné
comparé à l'est sur différents sites
vérifiés et on s'apercevra qu'il y a des
affaires on peut faire des affaires mais
pendant les proportions les syndicats
comparent et ça c'est important on a
tendance à jeter très vite sur la bonne
affaire parce qu'on veut être le premier
sur cette bonne affaire cela il faut
prendre le temps de relaxer et regarder
et aussi être
vigilant sur à qui on achète notamment
sur internet il faut être vigilant mais
tout ça c'est sur l'éco les consignes
que l'on donne toujours pour éviter les
arnaques sur internet bien vérifier
notamment le petit 4 nages c'était ps ça
c'est aussi par les internautes
reconnaissable dans les moeurs oui
est-ce que c'est dans cette période
comme c'est le cas pendant les soldes
est ce qu'on sont les mêmes règles en
termes d' échange de remboursements leur
disais tout à l'heure que ce n'est pas
encadrée de la même manière mais quels
sont les droits de ce sont des
consommateurs du voile à savoir d'où
vient le produit est aussi se méfier des
offres trop alléchantes on voit
volontiers pendant cette période des -50
mois 60%
là il faut il faut faire attention ça
peut déceler une mauvaise affaire je
n'existais pas si vous avez passé c'est
moins 60% effectivement par rapport au
prix du produit lorsqu'il est derrière
ces gars s'y voit par exemple mais c'est
pas nous c'est un produit qui se vend
pas donc il faut bien il faut bien faire
attention à tout cela et on encore une
fois par rapport aux prix des mêmes
produits qui existaient il ya quelques
jours
il ya passé et carla ce n'est pas vrai
d'autant que c'est que choisir alerte
sur les prix barrés qui peuvent être
trompeurs les prix barrés c'est les prix
de sortie des usines qui sont barrées et
qui sont pas forcément fidèle à la
réalité du marché puisque ils ont été
étiquetés s'est produit quelques mois
auparavant
donc là aujourd'hui enfin c'est si bon
oui donc ces prix ils font pas ne sont
pas
ne sont pas comment dire à la réalité du
marché c'est par rapport à quoi
donc il ya une vigilance là dessus ça
c'est des méthodes que vous dénoncez ah
oui a régulièrement le dénonça sur notre
site afin ethernet ou byada dans notre
revue vous disiez tout à l'heure
prendre le temps de comparer ça c'est
très très important
c'est très important oui parce que
encore une fois il faut voir exactement
si c'est le même produit par rapport à
la concurrence il faut faire marcher la
concurrence
est ce que ces mêmes produits que sur
les conditions de livraison s il ya des
frais est ce qu'il ya des engagements
par la suite souvent vous demande de
vous abonner à des newsletters
d le but c'est de fidéliser le client
est de capter des clients assez salée
pour les grandes enseignes donc pas
forcément se presser et en plus les
meilleures affaires on peut les faires
début décembre aussi à quelques à
quelques semaines de noël
c'est la première semaine de décembre
c'est encore bon c'est encore une bonne
période
alors pour terminer nous reste une
minute si on résume les quelques
conseils à donner à nos téléspectateurs
pour ce black friday les conseils à
donner ça ne pas se laisser abuser
prendre son temps à aller sur internet
comparer les différents produits
le même produit entre les différentes
sites différentes enseignes
on s'aperçoit souvent il n'existe pas
ailleurs et bien vérifier si c'est pas
un produit qui est déjà un peu anciens
qui a pas déjà quelques années et les
constructions on peut faire des bonnes
affaires pendant le black friday faut il
faut juste être un peu en fait religieux
dissident
merci beaucoup philippe le ray mercer
passé sur ce plateau administrateur
d'ufc que choisir région de versailles
on retrouve toute l'actualité du comité
local de cette association de défense
des consommateurs sur son site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
une conférence sur le réchauffement
climatique hier soir mardi les gradins
de la batterie à guyancourt était
quasiment plein pour accueillir jean
jouzel le climatologue mondialement
reconnu ancien vice président du giec
avec qui il a reçu en 2007 le prix nobel
de la paix
être régulièrement le grand public sur
les conséquences du réchauffement il est
à l'initiative du pacte finances climat
qui plaide notamment pour la création
d'une banque européenne dédiée jean
jouzel s'est prêté à l'exercice de nos
trois questions nous sommes dans un
contexte de réchauffement climatique lié
à notre activité et que les conséquences
de ce réchauffement climatique seront
examen extrêmement importante si nous ne
faisons rien pour en limiter en quiétude
en gros si rien n'était fait nous irions
vers des réchauffements 4 à 5 degrés à
la fin de ce siècle sévères pour les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui et des conséquences
dans beaucoup de domaines aussi bien sur
le séance mais aussi des événements
extrêmes qui deviendrait encore plus
extrême un peu parlé d' cyclone on peut
parler de sécheresses d'inondations dans
notre région de canicule on pourrait
imaginer des températures dépenses a
ponctuellement 50 degrés en france et
voilà donc des conséquences aussi sur la
biodiversité sur la pollution sur les
problèmes de santé d'environnement
l'élévation du niveau de la mer donc des
conséquences très importantes et qui ne
peuvent pas laisser indifférente
[Musique]
j'adhère complètement vous objectifs de
l'accord de paris limitait réchauffement
climatique au moins deux degrés voire un
degré 5 par rapport à aujourd'hui on a
déjà pris un degré mais c'est un
véritable défi par exemple pour avoir
des chances de rester autour de 2 degrés
il faudrait que les engagements de
l'accord de paris sur la période 2020
2030 soit multiplié par trois pour un
degré 5 x 5 donc on est loin du compte
la corde par est un succès mais les
largement insuffisant et d'autant plus
qu'il n'est pas respecté dans tous les
pays et que certains pays comme les
etats unis sont en train de le quitter
donc on voit bien la nécessité de
remonter dans l'ambition de l'accord de
paris mais on en voit bien la difficulté
également et c'est tout le défi de la
prochaine décennie si on veut lutter
efficacement contre le réchauffement
climatique est resté sur des
trajectoires qui permettrait aux jeunes
d'aujourd'hui de s'adapter au
réchauffement climatique ce ne sera
possible que si celui ci est limité à 2
degrés effectivement même à un degré
nuit par rapport aujourd'hui c'est un
constat très clair il faut aussi des
investissements sans les investissements
et bien
dénonçant des investissements
supplémentaires nous ne réussirons pas
au niveau de l'europe au niveau de la
france
cette transition par exemple au niveau
de la france on estime à 40 milliards 45
milliards supplémentaires d'argent qu'il
faudrait injecter dans le système
disons dans notre économie pour réussir
la transition élargi
donc ils ont la proposition c'est
effectivement la création de banques
européennes pour le climat la
biodiversité avec des prêts
préférentiels mais aussi d'un budget
européen dédié de l'ordre de 100
milliards d'euros chaque année dont une
partie dédiée d'ailleurs à l'aide pour
l'afrique une partie dédiée à la
recherche
voilà et c'est ce pacte climat finances
climat que nous mettons en avant avec
aussi nous croyons l'homme l'idée n'est
pas la nécessité d'entériner ces deux
outils ces deux approches par un
référendum qui permettrait de tout au
moins de pérenniser cette ce pacte donc
l'idée l'idée force du pack clients ce
climat ça vient du constat que les
investissements sont actuellement
insuffisant que ces investissements
doivent être faits au niveau de l'europe
et bien sûr aussi qu'ils seront
créateurs d'emplois et finalement de
bien-être pour les populations
européennes quelques heures avant
l'intervention de jean jouzel une autre
conférence se tenait à aiguille en cours
ce mardi la quatrième organisée par le
club climat énergie de saint quentin en
yvelines le thème cette année
l'autoconsommation et le consom'acteur
pour une meilleure transition
énergétique 180 entreprises se sont
réunis dans l'auditorium et de briques
challenger mathilde domini consommer
soi-même l'énergie que l'on a produites
sur place c'est le thème de la quatrième
conférence du club climat énergie une
conférence qui se déroule dans un
bâtiment entièrement basé sur la
transition énergétique
vous êtes ici dans un bâtiment en
challenger qui est un exemple même de
l'autoconsommation puisque bien que le
bâtiment date de 1988 il a été
intégralement rénovés
au début des années 2010 dont entre 2010
et 2014 pour devenir maintenant un
bâtiment à énergie positive et qu'il
rejette zéro gramme de co2 l'engagement
de 50 ans les mines pour la transition
énergétique permet aux entreprises du
territoire de repenser leur façon de
consommer et trouver des solutions sur
le long terme
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on arrive à
construire des bâtiments qui ont des
conditions de d'exploitation l'énergique
sous quasiment neutre c'est pas facile
mais on a on atteint et on vise demain
atteint de ça pour beaucoup de bâtiments
alors presque une neutralité entre la
dépense d'énergie d'affaires location
énergie donc et le coup on divise par on
vise effectivement de divisé quasiment
par 10 le coût de l'énergie des conseils
sur comment passer à l'autoconsommation
des résultats d'analysés de projet lors
de tables rondes
chaque entreprise expose sa gestion de
la transition énergétique
nous souhaitons présenter aujourd'hui à
la fois les réussites ce qu'on a obtenu
comme résultat les grandes leçons du
projet également les obstacles pour
expliquer que ce n'est pas si facile
aujourd'hui dans le cadre actuel est
bien de pouvoir de porter ce genre
d'offres parce que finalement
aujourd'hui les clients sont intéressés
par la thématique n'ont toujours une
difficulté par rapport aux aspects
économiques étant donné qu'il est encore
difficile de rentabiliser ce genre
d'offre et angie a développé dans le
cadre du projet nice m'a révélé une
offre complète intégrant la fois la
gestion locale de l'énergie dans une
démarche d'efficacité énergétique
globale permettant aux clients de
contrôler leurs factures des arguments
de poids pour toutes les entreprises qui
sont sensibles aux enjeux liés à la
protection de l'environnement
l'autoconsommation un projet en voie de
développement pour consommer localement
et devenir consom'acteurs et puis comme
chaque mercredi notre petit tour dans
les salles de cinéma du territoire ce
soir direction l'espace philippe noiret
aux clayes-sous-bois la programmation de
la salle au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude
[Musique]
cette semaine dans l'espace philippe
noiret des clayes-sous-bois nous avons
le temps attendue libérée délivré et oui
vous l'aurez reconnu la reine des neiges
2 est programmé pour au moins deux
semaines à l'espace philippe noiret l
intrigue du film tourne autour de ce
questionnement pourquoi elsa est elle
née avec des pouvoirs magiques
son rêve est de le découvrir avec l'aide
de ses amis anna christophe olha fait
semaine nous vous donnons également
rendez vous pour notre événement cinéma
jeudi 28 novembre à 14 heures ce sera si
n'était ou café en vous faisant
redécouvrir le film lulu femme nue et de
solveig anspach avec karin viard
vous la retrouverez également dans le
film chansons douces programmé à
l'espace philippe noiret la semaine
prochaine cette semaine nous avons
également le film à couteaux tirés de
ryan johnson un drame policier riche en
couleurs surmonté de touche d'humour
vous transportera dans un univers
semblable au célèbre jeu de société
super credo harlan trombert en place le
docteur lenoir ce célèbre auteur de
polar est retrouvé mort dans sa
somptueuse propriété
le soir de ses 85 ans c'est le détective
benoît blanc interprété par le
charismatique daniel craig qui est alors
engagée par un commanditaire anonyme
afin d'élucider la faire mais entre la
famille d'alan qui s'entredéchirent et
son personnel qui lui reste dévoué blanc
plonge dans les méandres d'une enquête
mouvementée mais leurs mensonges et
fausses pistes où les rebondissements
s'enchaînent à un rythme effréné
jusqu'à la toute dernière minute une
oeuvre qui sera vous plaire c'est
pourquoi nous vous invitons à venir la
voir à l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce journal belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]
oh